[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle zachary levi je devrais
avoir une petite étiquette et je joue shazam
nous établissons tous quelque chose de très spécial
sur le premier film et dans la théorie shazam
des dieux nous développons cela
maintenant ils doivent équilibrer leur vie  avec
être des super-héros c'est là que vous
traînez avec vos amis super-héros n'est-ce pas
[Musique]
ces déesses
viennent dans notre monde
nos incroyables nouveaux méchants
lucy lou et helen
mirren elle est calypso kick-ass
nous avons des créatures mythologiques minotaures
harpies et dragons
quand je  parler de mises à niveau nous avons eu une
mise à niveau énorme dans le costume de plus grandes
séquences d'action de plus grands décors nous allons
d'athènes à philadelphie nous allons
du rocher de l'éternité et de la bibliothèque de l'
éternité au royaume des dieux afin que nous
puissions aller dans des environnements qui  n'ont
jamais été explorés dans le premier téléphone
nous l'avons tous les trois deux un
shazam la fureur des dieux
amène l'excitation et l'action
à un tout autre niveau
ça va être plus un spectacle
c'est amusant  tout autour de
vous êtes en magasin pour un régal vous tous